privacy experts say people participating
the new 10 years social media challenge
may be unknowingly sharing sensitive
information have you done that yet
Facebook Twitter and Instagram users are
posting photos of themselves a decade
apart with a hashtag ten year challenge
some well-known people have gotten in on
the fun but the millions of publicly
shared photos can be a treasure trove of
information for companies working with
facial recognition and artificial
intelligence data and emerging
technology consultant Kate O'Neil warned
in a Wired opinion piece that's out
right now thanks to this meme there's
now a very large data set of carefully
curated photos the people from roughly
10 years ago and now similar concerns
were raised last year about Google's
arts and culture app it matched people
with artwork where artwork that
supposedly looked like them google says
it discarded users selfies once the
matches were found the website popped
sugar released its own app for finding
celebrity doppelgangers the company
later revealed photos submitted for its
twinning challenge were initially stored
on an unsecured server also many
Instagram users who created collages of
their top nine most liked posts of 2018
may have given their email addresses and
other user data to a company in Uruguay
really Wow regarding the ten year
challenge Facebook told CBS News quote
our face recognition symptoms are not
tracking studying or aware of this mean
wired senior writer and CBS News
contributor Izzy Lipowski is here good
morning morning so facebook says look
this was a user-generated mean they
didn't have anything to do with it but
how could Facebook use these photos
right so there's nothing inherently bad
about this it was it was all in good fun
generated by users but what we have to
think about is what we're giving away
when we're having this fun right and so
in the case of the ten year challenge it
is this streamline to organize data set
that shows what you look like ten years
ago what you look like now and if you
are trying to train a machine learning
algorithm to learn how people aged this
is something that Facebook could do this
is something that other researchers
might want to do this gives you a pretty
nifty way of doing that so again I think
this is just a moment to think about
this because it's not just the ten year
challenge these types of viral
challenges and memes are popping up all
the time and a lot of times
people don't know what company is behind
us is Facebook currently using though a
method of facial recognition Facebook is
yes so for instance if you upload the
photo or somebody uploads the photo of
you and might say hey is this you do you
want to tag yourself do you want to tag
your friends so Facebook is proactively
doing that behind the scenes Facebook is
also using image recognition technology
for really valuable purposes to spot
spam to spot graphic violence and other
content it doesn't want on there so
there are definitely positive uses of
facial recognition technology we should
want Facebook to get better at it but as
users we should want to know when our
information is being used for those
purposes this just seemed like harmless
fun to me honestly I would have done it
is see if I could have found a picture
from 2009 I got tired of looking at so
what what should people be what should
they look out for if they're thinking
about doing it right well I think that
for now it's all good fun but I think
one thing that's really important to
know is that there's a hashtag
associated with it right so if you have
a public Instagram page for instance and
somebody searches the ten year challenge
hashtag millions of photos pop up and so
even if Facebook isn't using that
remember all of the researchers who have
access to these public hashtags and
could use them for who knows what means
so if you are concerned about this but
you still want to participate check your
privacy settings make sure that you're
only sharing it with friends and people
you know so this seems like an issue of
digital hygiene just sort of think twice
before you go stumbling into something
that seems like fun but is there a
specific way this could come back and
harm me I mean if if it created an
algorithm to to figure out my aging how
is that going to ultimately hurt me well
there right so from Facebook's point of
view I don't think that Facebook is
going to hurt you but people experts
wonder about how this could be used by
for instance insurance companies are
they looking at whether you tend to be
aging a little bit faster than the rest
of us so they'll take you as a client
exactly Aereo's but this is what
researchers in the field are thinking
about a lot of this comes down to
privacy and many people are now
suggesting privacy legislation right
even Tim Cook wrote an op-ed today how
realistic is that I mean is the genie
out of the bottle now that the
technology is there well I think what's
promising is that we are seeing these
tech baby
step up for so long they have been
allergic to regulation but now we have
Tim Cook out there we also have
companies that gobble up a lot of data
Google Facebook coming out and saying we
too want federal privacy regulation and
I think that that is partly in response
to the public outcry but partly because
they see it on the horizon and they want
to have a say in how strict it's going
to be so they want to be out there
lobbying on Capitol Hill saying this is
what we want to see this is what we feel
would [ __ ] us and so they want to be
part of this conversation if it is going
to happen of course we know the
political system we're living in and how
how practical is is any regulation but I
think that if there's going to be
something it's going to happen this year
all right thank you Izzy if I did guess
I would say you're Isadora also known as
is a durable adorable
thank you I'm just having a little fun
with you Thank You Izzy